I've got some great follow up on this
story about US ambassador to the
Netherlands pete hoekstra or Hoekstra
some people told me after last week's
stories the way that his last name is
pronounced he is finally admitted that
his claims about the no-go zones in the
netherlands weren't true
this started to get attention when a
couple of weeks ago pete hoekstra told a
dutch reporter during an interview that
claims that he said there are no go
zones and the burning of politicians in
the netherlands were fake news and then
minutes later he denied ever having
called it fake news it was bizarre right
so to start this out this is what
started the entire controversy back in
December speaking of threats at one
point you mentioned in a debate that
there are no go zones in the Netherlands
and that cars and politicians are being
set on fire and I didn't say that that
is actually an incorrect statement yeah
we would call it fake news I never said
that but I said no it's not what I said
the Islamic movement is now gotten to a
point where they have put Europe into
chaos chaos in the Netherlands there are
cars being burned there are politicians
that are being burned and yes there are
no go zones in the Netherlands you call
it fake news obviously I didn't call
that fake news I didn't use the word
today no okay so this is already
completely outrageous right so then at a
press conference in January this this
year last week Dutch reporters followed
up they did the right thing they asked
him are you going to retract what you
said about the fake news I'm sorry about
the no-go zones and the burning of
politicians or are you going to provide
examples of it any stand he looked like
a stunned puppy here's a reminder of
what that went like our politicians
being burned in the Netherlands in the
past is that something you believe yes
or no
I'm not revisiting the issue as did you
read the dwelt over the fireplace from
Johnny's if you're truly an honest and
wise man which you please take back the
remark about burned politicians or named
a politician that was burned in the
Netherlands thank you why don't you
answer the question answer the question
this has not happened and then with a
little bit of overlap with that last
clip here is how it continued and it was
not good please if there's nothing so he
is finally admitted that it wasn't true
on Friday Hoekstra said to a Dutch
newspaper called The Telegraph that he
was shocked by his own comments and that
they are wrong quote that was a wrong
statement that was just wrong that one
shocked me personally because while you
know there have been other issues in
other countries in Europe you know that
has never been the circumstances here I
am seriously confused about this he said
he was shocked by his own prior
statements like he was so wrong about
what he said that he shocked even
himself
Wow and if he was shocked that he said
it I'd want to know why like did he say
it for political gain knowing it was a
lie did he believe it at the time but he
was really confused how do you explain
being shocked by your own lies and now I
I know I've been talking about this a
lot lately because of Trump but is it
possible pete hoekstra has dementia and
i only ask this because in the interview
that he gave last month he called the
reference to his claims fake
News and then like moments later in the
same interview he said I never said that
I never called it fake news what
explanation is there for that like this
guy either is having some kind of
cognitive issue or he's just a terribly
bad liar and I commend the Dutch press
here right we have to commend the Dutch
press I think he is apologizing and
expressing some remorse and now he's
trying to distance himself from what he
said but how he's doing it by saying
that he was shocked by what he said I
found my own comments shocking and
they're certainly not true good for the
Dutch press right if they didn't let
this guy off the hook during the press
conferences they stayed on him for close
to a month now and eventually he
admitted it he was flat-out wrong and
American reporters should do this I've
said before when sarah huckabee sander
starts to filibuster and she won't
answer the questions and she just moves
on to the next reporter the next
reporter has to say they need a pact in
the White House press room hold on Sarah
you didn't answer my colleagues question
and even if they're from a different
news outlet and you want to get your
question in have some kind of pact and
solidarity where you're not going to
allow what what Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is allowed to do to happen and take this
as a guide for that I think it's
excellent well I do wonder if you
employed the strategy on Sarah Huckabee
Sanders or on Donald Trump she'd walk
they would they back off of those
comments eventually could have take him
a week before they decided to retract
their statement here's how it would go
down more than likely until you
completely reset the expectations in the
short term if one day the White House
press corps decides to do this to Sarah
Huckabee Sanders when she won't answer a
question initially if she just keeps
getting the same question she'll leave
she'll say okay guys that's it we're
done here and she'll fill frame it as
the press corps was being childish and
the press corps was being rude by
repeatedly asking the same question over
the long term one of two things would
happen either this would become expected
from the White House press corps and the
White House would have to start at least
making an attempt to appear to answer
questions or they would just stop doing
the briefings and remember with Sean
Spicer when Sean Spicer was White House
press secretary before Sarah Huckabee
Sanders replaced him there
a period in there where he said I'm
gonna start holding the briefings
off-camera or in my office with only
audio recording and I'm gonna limit
who's even allowed to come in because if
you're just gonna be writing lies what
he considered to be lies you're not
gonna be allowed to participate they
will just start punishing people by
refusing them access which I believe if
there was total solidarity among the
press corps they wouldn't really be able
to do yeah or that any story any
questions pertaining to the Russia
investigation would be referred to Trump
Special Counsel Dorf or that the the
president's already spoken extensively
about a certain topic they do have outs
they have outs yeah and they would
attempt to use them desperately but at
least make them do that right put them
on the defensive the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad